by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley and today we have a
special treat and i know i say that
every single week but today we really do
have a special treat we are talking to a
guy named richard cooper from a little
youtube channel called entrepreneurs and
cars and by little i mean almost 600 000
subscribers and there's a reason for
that
richard
is a fantastic guy who has a message
about
self-improvement from men being the best
version of yourself
maximizing your success in business in
dating in fitness in life in general
that i think
many more people and many more men and
women too because there are a lot of
cold hard truth bombs that he drops on
his youtube page
i think the world needs to hear more of
this he's already become pretty popular
on youtube and on the internet in
general
you know i love his manner of speaking
i love that it gets to the point i love
that he's not afraid to tell the truth
about certain things that people dance
around a lot so
i've been watching his content for a
while i've been uh reading his books as
well
i was just rereading slash re-listening
to his audiobook the unplugged alpha
on the way over here to the studio today
and i just think it's something that if
you guys are unaware of rich cooper
uh you could benefit a lot
from
consuming some more of his content and
if you do know him i think this
conversation
is
going to unearth some amazing nuggets of
wisdom
for your life that anybody man woman
small child can benefit from so without
further ado here is my interview the
first full-length haters will say guest
richard cooper today we are joined by
richard cooper of the youtube pages
entrepreneurs and cars and the unplugged
alpha
let me give you a quick rundown of who
richard is if you don't know him
he's an entrepreneur an investor
a youtube content creator and i guess
you could say
life coach mail coach
all these things
and then in addition to that i'll give
you
the rundown of
what drew me to richard in the first
place
i love your direct manner of speaking i
love the content that you make that has
to do you know specifically with
male self-improvement you might say um
you're you're included in a broad
category of content creators that
loosely described as the manosphere
and uh at the haters we'll say podcast i
call it a fitness adjacent podcast we
talk about fitness but we talk about
lots of things that sort of branch off
from fitness and i think male excellence
you know encompasses fitness and many
other things that are related or fitness
might be the building block for so many
other things and i know that's part of
your message at least with martial arts
training and being in shape and you know
you don't go too much into the weeds in
it but i know that would be an
interesting launching off point
to talk to you about this and again
either just think you're somebody who
is a voice that many men that i talk to
who come to me for advice in particular
areas that i might have more expertise i
find myself sort of
funneling them to your page in many
instances to
learn about women to learn about you
know
confidence and and the mindset of
somebody who uh as you say can pursue
excellence
so would you say that's a fair
assessment of what you do and who you
are yeah that's a pretty good rundown
yeah yeah happy with that yeah nice
um
so i guess the the first question as i'm
re-listening to your book
what struck me is
you know i think the reason why you come
off as such a confident voice in this
arena is that you've been through the
lows you've been through
the trials and tribulations and seen
life when you're behaving in the
opposite way or you don't have your
[ __ ] figured out uh you know how bad
things can go so you've talked about uh
you know going through divorce having
depression uh even having suicidal
thoughts at some point i believe this
was
was it towards
i know the time frame you gave with like
2011 to 2016 but i wasn't sure exactly
when the low point was yeah that yeah
that low point was tied into the divorce
and um just stuff that was going on with
uh
provincial laws which were
essentially attacking the revenue source
of my main business at the time so yeah
that was um that was not a fun time yeah
yeah i talked about that in the intro of
my book yeah
um so
what are some things that
you know you made it out of that place
from a dark place where you're thinking
about suicide
what are some tricks that you use today
for psychological resilience when you
face difficulties when you face you know
even online criticism or or anything of
that nature
what are some go-to tactics that you
have
to keep plowing forward
um so as far as online criticism and i
love the name of your podcast by the way
thank you because because i do have a
lot of haters uh yeah but i always say
that haters are just confused admirers
um
the thing about about criticism is is it
never comes from above you does it right
like it's never i've never been
criticized by um guys that i would look
up to i've never heard criticism from
elon musk from richard branson
from superior gentlemen that are you
know that have done more with their
lives than i have obviously right yeah
um so it always comes from beneath you
uh critics are never above you they're
always beneath you and they try to bring
you down it's like
um
there was a there was a blog that james
altucher wrote a while ago that that got
forward to me quite a few years ago and
it really resonated it was it was
something along the lines of haters are
like pigs they want you to get down in
the mud and roll around with them and if
you just ignore them and let them have
their little spas they eventually go
away
the good thing about haters is nobody
talks about you more than your haters
they're your best marketers they never
shut up yeah
yeah i found that to be true especially
with you know driving the algorithm or
whatever on social media and uh
you know i i do think that
to me it's a sign of something right
you're creating an emotional effect in
somebody and uh you know they can't
really process what to do with it in my
case it's mostly men i mean pretty much
exclusively men um i find that if men
are for example mocking my physical
appearance it's like well i got you
didn't i because you're a man going on
another man's page you know talking
about his physical appearance as if
you know if you liked my physical
appearance you would be complimenting me
on that or you know expressing your
attraction to me
um do you
find that that has been sort of uh
correlated with your success as you've
grown in popularity and and grown in uh
you know notoriety yeah yeah it's all
it's all kind of tied into envy like um
people throw the hate and the criticism
at you not because they really
truthfully hate you or want to criticize
you it's but it's because they're
envious of you it's because they want to
be you generally speaking yeah yeah i
think i'd agree um so
you haven't always
had this enlightened perspective on life
um
how would you describe and i don't know
too much about you know
i think in your late 30s is where i kind
of
pick up on your story
and and where you were
uh as far as your belief system and
stuff like that
take us back to
when you were a teenager or in your 20s
what was that like for you and maybe
what were some of the things that you
would have wished you knew now
um wow
i spent a lot of time in my teenage
years and my 20s especially
driving fast cars and motorcycles
causing havoc in the middle of the night
doing that yeah and um working out you
know lifting weights um you know
developing a physique because for me
like when i was a kid you can see the
scars on my arm i uh yeah i pulled a
kettle of hot water on myself when i was
uh a toddler so a point that i don't
even
remember and
like growing up with uh buck teeth so i
had you know like um i don't know what
they call it today but you know like
that upper overbite you know like the
overbite the buck teeth you know scars
over my arms and my chest um
i didn't feel like i could get what i
wanted out of life but i always admired
guys like arnold schwarzenegger you know
for example because
um you know he came to a country that
was foreign to him did the work put you
know built a phenomenal physique uh you
know took mr olympia titles became a
highest paid movie star so guys like
that always inspired me so i spent a
good deal of my youth basically lifting
weights and driving fast bikes and
trying to figure out how to get girls
and get over whatever um was
holding me back mentally in my head
about how girls may not be attracted to
me you know because of my appearance for
example like having scars
um but i mean you learn real quick that
chicks kind of dig scars and the scars
are just proof that you were stronger
than whatever tried to kill you right
yeah yeah i really like that um
and i do think that's that's a point of
confusion for a lot of guys is getting
hung up on physical imperfections and i
think maybe because we look at women and
go well i'm so judgmental of their
physical appearance or i have this
certain way that it often takes along
like we lag as far as understanding
what women are
really attracted to you know and i don't
think that's even in the modern
discourse and so that's why you know
my impetus in getting some of guests
like you
who who talk about these things is you
don't really see this in mainstream
media you know the nuts and bolts of
like
not talking about romantic comedy bs
what are women actually attracted to
scars being one of them or just you know
physical appearance
and the things that men get insecure
about might not be the things that she
gives a [ __ ] about
maybe you could elaborate a little bit
on
what you've found over the years women
are actually attracted to versus you
know what we kind of assume they are or
yeah women are attracted to winners you
know just boils down to that you know um
i've often said that women hang out at
the finish line and pick the winners um
that ruffles feathers it ruffles women's
feathers because then it exposes the
fact that they always want the best they
can get yeah they want the winner and
that pisses off guys that can't win or
or struggle you know figure out how to
win in life
um so yeah like you'll hear it from all
kinds of different angles but at the end
of the day i mean like we live in a
culture in a society today where a lot
of guys are really weak and pussified
and
that's a function of a lot of things
coming at them from a whole different
you know number of angles i mean we
could spend three hours talking about
that
but
it's it's never been easier for guys to
stand out from the crowd you know from
being perfectly honest like that like
you said earlier a lot of dudes get
really obsessed and um like they just
spend way too much time on watching
these uh i call them black pill channels
because they're these guys that are just
like oh if your jawline's not straight
like marks you know you're never going
to get a girl or if you don't have
muscles like him you know sort of thing
you're never going to get the girl or
girls will just use you until they can
find a better deal or the richer guys
sort of thing and that's not entirely
true like women do have the capacity to
pair bond to guys if you're a solid guy
and you have good frame and you know how
to deal with women but um yeah there's a
lot going on with those dynamics my
friend yeah and i would say that's an
interesting distinction for those people
who aren't uh sort of familiar with the
jargon the black pill maybe
one way that i think about it is sort of
a hopelessness a
you know a victim mentality of like i
was born with these genetics and
therefore it means that i will never you
know
yeah it's a vivid mindset yeah big time
like one of the
most common complaints you hear is like
well i'm five foot six i'll never get a
check and it's like yeah really because
i had a roommate for about five or six
years it was about five four five five
and he was a slayer yeah and it's like
you know you can't do anything about
your height but i mean like you can max
out in other areas of your life right
you can be charismatic you can be
charming you know you can be captivating
you know you can obviously make a lot of
money you know if you're short then you
better be short-jacked and funny and and
you know have something going
um you know going on in your life but um
a lot of guys would just stop at that be
like you know what um you know i got
dealt a shitty hand um there's nothing i
can do
all these people i hate them for
whatever reason because they're tall or
they get girls and i don't
and uh they just wallow in that misery
and
it's sad you know in one regard but in
the other regard it's like okay there's
it's easier for guys that are doing the
work to get the girls or more girls if
they want you know yeah yeah and it
brings a story to mind i knew this
a female friend of mine who is probably
six feet tall you know like a thick
white girl uh
and very beautiful but you know as
obviously most girls who are that tall
are going to be like yo you got to be
six feet or more or whatever have some
sort of height standard
she ends up marrying a guy who's
probably five five
and uh you know i've heard her tell the
story of it she told in one of these
like storytelling festival kind of
things we heard the long form you know
written out story version of it
and it basically came down to the dude
being like oh you're going to disqualify
me because i'm like get over yourself
[ __ ] and that kind of mindset and i've
met the guy in person i'm like he is
very confident and you just you can tell
that's not a hang up for him and he's
smart he's compelling uh these are all
you know and charisma for example is i
do believe some people are born with
charisma but it is something you can
look up online and go what do
charismatic people act like you know um
what's their body language i heard that
prince did this you know when he like
was trying to figure out how to perform
on stage so even people we think of as
you know these amazing performers who
must have been like that their entire
life it's like even that even this
notion of charisma which we kind of
intuitively think that uh people are
born with this or they're not you can
figure this out it's just a matter of
you know i i think one of the things
that i think about when i think of your
channel is
because i recently read this book the
ego is the enemy um
really you know because people use the
word ego all the time but what does that
really mean to have an ego problem and
to me it boils down to not being in
touch with reality
and as a guy you're not afforded that
luxury if you want to succeed in life
right in the long term at least
and so
one of the things that i hear you repeat
a lot is is
uh chase excellence right don't chase
women chase excellence and and make your
dent in the world and i guess i wanted
to set that up in contrast to
i think most guys who who
have an entree into
pickup or whatever might come from the
game you know like in 2005 and i
remember being enthralled with this book
and it you know kind of blows your mind
it's like oh my god you know you can be
this short ugly guy or whatever
and there's things you can say and do
and tricks and language that you can
utilize to get women who you
you know previously thought were out of
your league however i would now consider
that as sort of like a slice of it
because it is fake or you're trying to
be somebody else
but a lot of these principles hold that
you're sort of pretending to be this way
if you actually chase excellence you can
be that so
maybe you could talk a little bit about
what that means to you to chase
excellence and put your debt in the
world yeah i usually phrase it along the
lines of chase excellence not women
because
guys will get preoccupied with
girls to such degree that it's just a
[ __ ] distraction
um
and what they'll end up doing it's like
you know i met this girl in a dating app
and she um you know she expressed
interest and then um
you know i did this thing the other
thing and i'll do screenshots of like
the text thread or like the thread on
the dating app and it's just like blah
blah blah and he doesn't even get to the
point of getting the number and like you
know setting up the date and he wonders
why they get ghosted and it's like
because you're spending way too much
time chasing these girls
and
see women are like cats right i mean if
you ever see it i'm not a big fan of cat
but i mean like you know when you see
the cats you know in somebody's house
they generally kind of like run away
from you if you try to pet them or chase
them down it's only when you're sitting
down they'll hop up on your lap they'll
spin around put their tail up in the air
and you know show you their stuff and
they'll sit down and start purring
that's what that's what women are
basically like and if you chase them
then they generally don't respond to it
you've got to you've got to have an aura
of indifference of you know like a
certain degree of arrogance and even ego
to some degree as well yeah if you want
to be good at attracting women but the
reason why i get guys to lean more on
the chasing excellence part is because
if you're a world-class guy right and
you've maxed out on
unplugging from society's lies on looks
on money on your status your social
influence you've got good game you've
got good frame with women you're
captivating you're not a boring guy
women are easy right they're they're not
difficult to attract or keep around and
you can keep multiples of them around
too
yeah
yeah that's a great point and uh
i do think that's yeah the second part
of like chase excellent not women
because
if you are good enough if you're good
enough at something if you're competent
enough if you have confidence if if you
have any outward sign
you know that you're a winner in any
regard or you just hold yourself in a
social situation i mean i've got women
before you know when i didn't have any
money and i'm living with my mom but i
knew that like yes within this certain
social dynamic um
i'm impressive to them to some degree
and that has really very little to do
with these other things that we you know
you might a black build guy might
consider deal breakers if not having
money you're not having looks or or
whatever because you know i've been on
i've looked the same way and had
drastically different results you know
with women sort of based on
my behavior but i just i've never been
in a situation where you know you're
performing on stage or you're playing a
sport and you do really well or any of
these things where
you're elevated in some way as a winner
and it was hard to get women after right
because they come to you yes
it's almost impossible i mean
one of the um things that i picked up on
you know this was long before i got red
pill but
um
if you ever go to a speaking gig or a
speaking event and
there's a guy on the stage
and
there's an audience full of people that
admire him for whatever it is that he's
talking about standing ovation
that is that is a time if if if your
wife your girlfriend your chick a woman
you're dating even women you're not
dating are in the room they
automatically look at you and they're
like wow this guy is is awesome yeah
everybody's applauding him um you know
the lights are on and the cameras are on
him sort of thing
those are the guys that that they get
turned on you know by the most yeah
there's um there's a couple of handsome
looking dating coaches out there that
cater their business to women
and
i've seen a few of these videos where
they're up on the stage like there's
this handsome um australian i can't
remember his uh name but he's up on the
stage and like the room is filled with
like fives and sixes you know at best
but
you can i mean you can pick up on the
moisture in the room right like
there i think i know you're talking
about i know his name but he like yeah
and he's genuinely addressing them like
this is your problem and yeah you know
and you know they're sitting there you
know think of themselves okay now that
i've listened to his talk and i want to
be with him i'm i'm probably not going
to get him because there's 100 other
women in this room um but they
legitimately you know like leave and
think themselves okay well i'm going to
go and get a guy just like him right
like that's what you want
yeah do you think stuff like that is
useful for women like i i don't think
i've seen any clips beyond just this guy
but i'm like like you know the way
you're phrasing it and now that i think
about it it's like the guy kind of is
he's extremely true if we're thinking
about the same guy which i think we are
he's very charming yeah you know yeah um
is it
is useful to women is that what you're
asking me yeah
um that's a good question
see
women get lied to just like guys get
lied to right like yeah
a lot of the messaging that women get
from mainstream narratives and and
sources is is you know just be yourself
you're beautiful at any weight
um
like you know women today are not nearly
as feminine as they were when i was a
kid um tattoos on women are very common
when i was a teenager in my 20s it was
very uncommon um
disagreeable uh boss [ __ ] you know like
you see this hashtag around like boss
[ __ ] boss girl you know whatever yeah
like disagreeable women are very common
today because they've been told you know
as a function of decades of you know
brainwashing of cultural brainwashing to
believe that they should you know behave
like men and that's why they go out and
chase degrees and you know get get
pretty decent you know corporate jobs
make good money have their own house in
their own car
and then they start looking around and
they you're like where did all the good
guys go you know sort of yeah and all
the good guys are around their age with
all the bank and you know they've chased
the excellence and they've got the nice
cars and the houses and all that stuff
and they're dating younger hotter women
that are more fertile that haven't you
know been around the block uh 50 times
sort of thing um
so i think society's done a disservice
to women and i think women you know
drank drank the [ __ ] and gotten drunk
on that to a pretty significant degree
like it's it's
it's easier in some regards to date
today than what it used to be but it's
also more difficult if you haven't done
the work and you don't understand the
dynamics of attraction
right yeah and i think that sort of is
you know imperative upon men to
understand those things but as you're
talking i kind of you know maybe think
like is there really
is there a woman oh sphere out there you
know that that is trying to break down
these truths to women and i see a little
bit although it's mostly on
like these other sort of manosphere
podcasts or platforms um you know
because that's like i mentioned earlier
where men confuse the things that
they're attracted to for the things that
women will be attracted to them for
and likewise women uh you know often
assume well i want a guy who has a
degree and a successful job and is in
his 30s and well established for you
know
things that men will also be attracted
to them for
um yeah most of the women that um
consume female delivered content or
female catered content on how to get
high value guys like that's a big
catchphrase that's been going around for
a while you know yeah high value men you
know sort of thing
they only come to the realization that
they need to hear this information when
it's too late for them after they've hit
what's called the wall right because
after about 28 29 30 or so
women women hit this epiphany phase in
their life where they're like okay i've
spent my entire 20s um partying drinking
traveling the world uh sleeping with a
bunch of alpha males um you know running
up a notch count and then they're like
why can't all of my girlfriends are
getting married or some of my
girlfriends are getting married and
having families and the biological clock
starts ticking and then they go looking
for information on why they can't get
the guy that they want and that's when
they run across
i mean about five percent of my audience
is female and if i'm being honest half
of the female audience loves my stuff
the other half of it hates me because i
reveal the truth right i see i've seen
why some of your content where they
argue with you and that's who is
entertaining but i think some of them
yeah you know like i've done a couple of
podcast sessions with um there was one
in particular where i did probably about
90 minutes straight with one woman yeah
and she sent me this long email um
and uh you know mid-thirties you know
had a boyfriend you know your typical
avatar right
and you know she was struggling to deal
with the reality of the sexual
marketplace and her value on it
and women have this overestimated view
of what they're worth
um to
high value men right yeah um and then
you kind of have to take that down a few
notches but they don't want to hear that
right you know they don't want to hear
well you're a single mom with two kids
from two different fathers
i don't really care about your degree it
doesn't impress me uh you've got a pot
of gold it doesn't matter you don't
share it with men anyway so you're like
what do you bring to the table aside
from some baggage and you know like a
few years of beauty left before you hit
menopause you know for being honest
you know it's and it's a brutal truth
though because you're not going to hear
that and almost like you know i remember
the manosphere sort of being framed to
me or
as like misogynistic and you do it's
kind of relegated a lot to youtube
because obviously you're not going to
see
a sort of you know blunt message like
that uh you know in mainstream media
but when i hear that now obviously i've
become desensitized to it but it's like
it's something that i wish women would
hear earlier because as you've mentioned
i don't need to hear it earlier though
mark because when you're young and
beautiful guys are throwing themselves
at them right right like even a six
that's on instagram with a decent
following can have an only fans making
twenty thousand dollars a month um right
you know like a six can go on on
instagram and post a few you know
attractive photos and some bathing
attire with the right lighting and some
filters and get tons of thirsty betas
hitting her up in her dms so when women
are young they don't
they don't want to hear this information
it's only when they get older and they
come to the realization that wow things
are a lot more difficult than i thought
it was and guys my age generally don't
want like the guys that i want around my
age generally don't want to choose me
because of whatever you know like insert
baggage sort of thing they're going for
the younger prettier girls right because
women hit their peak around 22 23.
they've done surveys um i've read a lot
of evo psych books really really good um
stuff if you know your audience is into
that um
there's um
there's a book called the evolution of
desire which i think is probably one of
the better ones but um when they survey
men from around the world regardless of
age whether they're 19 or 70 from any
culture in the world
overwhelmingly all men you know if you
show them pictures of like beautiful
women from 20s you know like all the way
up to like 65 sort of thing
overwhelmingly they'll always pick about
22-23 right so women peak at that age
because women are beauty objects to men
but men they don't peak till later on in
life right like we don't usually peak
until
mid-30s sometimes sometimes you can push
it back in the late 30s early 40s
depending on your genetics if you're a
good-looking guy like how old are you
i'm 38. yeah so like a guy like you like
you're probably right near the peak your
sexual market value right i mean you can
probably push it back a few more years
of course but that's where guys peak and
that frustrates women your age because
they'd probably like to get with you or
try to lock you down or to get you to
settle down with them
um but they struggle to get guys like
that to really commit to them right yeah
no i agree and that's a great uh that
phrase
that i didn't know until somewhat
recently the past few years the sexual
marketplace value you know when i'm
having these longer interview podcasts
and i really need to make sure to focus
on the person that i'm talking to for
the entire time and not drift off into
daydreaming about having bigger muscles
the product that i use is happy hippo
kratom if you go to
happyhippopurples.com right now
and use promo code thick boy with three
c's you can get the products that i use
every time i'm on this podcast i think
you'll like them and i think they might
help you too if you need to talk to
people and really hone in and get in the
zone and focus
on that person happy about reals.com
promo code thick boy for 20 percent off
not 20 platypus off 20
off got it do it well it's another hot
summer day
and yes i'm in another oak and stone
shirt somebody said to me yesterday man
that that fabric
looks really thick and sturdy it was tim
kennedy i'll be honest right and i said
what's funny is
it looks that way because it is really
nice material but it's breathable i wear
it on the plane i wear it outside in the
summer heat to do my job
and you know what i'm sweating more in
my athletic pants not this bad boy
because it's breathable amazing cotton
from
oakenstoneclothing.com go there right
now use code hello for 10 off and get
you a fancy phenomenal shirt that not
only looks good not only will hold up to
use after use after wear after wear it
will also
keep you breathing on your skin area
talking about the epidermis yeah
is going to be looking and feeling great
you know some of these guys that you'll
talk to in their early 20s they they
feel hopeless because again that women
of the woman of 23 years old 22 isn't
interested in them right and they don't
know why and they think it's a
reflection
of of who they are as a person and they
get helpless about it and and so i think
it's a really great message to be able
to bring to guys like no you can you can
start here and you know [ __ ] this for
right now you know have your fun and if
opportunities arise that's great but
really you should be looking towards the
long term of being the best version of
yourself you know in uh your mid to late
30s and i even noticed that like i you
know it was sort of surprising to me
it's like but yeah you turn a certain
age and you have a certain level of
experience or gravitas or whatever in
conjunction with you know getting
yourself in shape obviously i think if i
was you know 38 and super fat it
wouldn't be you know
the best uh situation for me as far as
attracting women but i have noticed that
and i think that's something that a lot
of guys don't realize is that they're at
such a low point you know in their early
20s when everybody's telling them you
know their life should be about
chasing women and uh and they don't have
any long-term perspective you know or
idea of what you know men want so
there's always going to be this mismatch
and i think that's a funny pairing too
of like
because there's a lot of shame around
you know guys you know in their 30s even
like leonardo dicaprio like the joke of
like oh my god he only is yeah oh he
only dates 25 year olds like who gives a
[ __ ] uh i think you know and it's hard
to explain that i think to either a
woman or a blue pill guy who
considers that to be like
i've even heard it be termed like a form
of pedophilia which i think is obviously
a complete bastardization of that word
but it's like there are people really
out there and obviously you know
led by certain groups of people uh who
[Music]
want to completely shame that kind of
behavior but as you said it's a
scientific fact that if you go around
the world and say what do you like you
know there's a certain answer and i'm
sure it'd be the same for women right
it's like what are you actually
attracted to uh you know and we can
answer that question with with looks and
age but also probably much more than
that
um
go ahead yeah women are attracted to the
to the older seasoned gentleman um and
when i say older like i'm again you know
i'm talking like mid 30s to late 30s
like a guy that's in that age bracket
that's again maxed out in every area of
his life um and
leads an interesting life is captivating
has status and money and all that sort
of stuff
he can you know like a guy like leonardo
you know dicaprio as you mentioned it's
very easy for him to you know if she if
she gets out of line if she's difficult
or whatever he or he gets bored with her
all right i'll go in you know like she
got to 25 26 i'll go get another 22 23
year old like it's easy for him yeah
difficult but yeah uh society will shame
guys like that and
when they do
um you know points and sputter at guys
and say
you're immature why don't you find a
woman you know like your own age it's
like well why don't you settle down with
a broke guy you know you generally don't
right i mean yeah because women are
hypergamous they want the best guy that
they can get and men are success objects
to women and women are beauty objects to
men so why wouldn't leonardo dic you
know dicaprio find young youthful you
know early 20 year old women to date of
course he's going to like why wouldn't
he
yeah and that's about that option yeah
yeah exactly um
and i think
the fact that other men aren't doing
that is often just a reflection of the
fact that they don't have those
opportunities i don't have that option
is what it is down to yeah yeah so
whenever guys shame you know like guys
that are older for dating younger women
um you know i've
i've had people say you know when i was
dating a younger chick you know
something like oh you know so where's
your twinkie today you know sort of
thing and it's like you're just jealous
because your wife's overweight
and she's all you got and you're
probably not even sleeping with her
right right yeah yeah i think yeah that
that can come from that can come from
women that can come from guys who are
sort of self-justifying their situation
you know and whether that's in a
relationship or or anything and i think
i've you know i've received that more
because i've made myself a sort of
focal point
i make a lot of my content about working
out i try to keep it in a
tongue-in-cheek way but still people
will you know project a lot onto me that
this is like all i do or my entire
personality or whatever and it's like
you know
again not coming from guys who are
really in shape you know
not coming from guys who even understand
the pleasure of working out and why i
would want to sort of lead with that in
any way
and maybe that's something we can talk
about i'd love to talk to you about more
like you know
when you coach guys and consult guys
like
how
you advise them to sort of become more
masculine versions of themselves and
maybe we could start with your fitness
game i saw some pictures of you online
as i was looking up uh you know some
more information about you
and you are you 49 years old yeah i'm in
my late 40s yeah so
you're 49 and you're like when i look at
your physique i go i'd love to be in
that kind of shape at your age often one
one attack people give to me it's like
okay you look good now but you know by
the time you're 50 you're going to be
like a melted candle or you know they
have some idea of like it's all going to
suddenly go away and it's like well
but as long as i keep working out i'm
going to look fine so i would say for
most men you probably have a somewhat
ideal physique as far as you know a
balance you don't look reutered out or
anything you have a great chest and
shoulders you're very lean
and
you don't draw too much attention to
like you know i i like to try to have a
physique that you can kind of put
clothes on and it doesn't look like
you're you know a competitive
bodybuilder or something like that so
yeah you know that's probably the best
way to define it i mean i always i
always try to distill it down to having
a swimmer's body you know when it comes
to guys and you know define in
masculinity because that seems to be
what what women are generally most
attracted to yeah
women are generally not attracted to
guys that look like mr olympia and they
also are generally not attracted to
scrawny guys either there's some
exceptions like um who's that dork
that's dating kim kardashian
pete davidson that guy yeah yeah like
you know if a guy like that can get
uh
probably like what's considered a uh
a sex icon you know to most guys
um yeah it's it's mostly because he's
successful obviously captivating and
charming but he's not the most like
physically fit guy like i could probably
beat his ass with an arm you know tied
behind my back or just flick him like
that and he would fall over yeah but um
but but having the optics of masculinity
just makes dealing with life in general
not just getting women but dealing with
life in general a lot easier i mean if
you walk into a room and you look good
with clothes on people notice that right
i mean if you wear fitted clothing or
tailored clothing you know if you're
wearing like a shirt or a suit or
something like that it fits you properly
and people notice that i mean like one
of the first things that i ask guys when
i do consults with them is as i try to
establish like okay like you know when
they're dealing with female problems
it's like okay well what do you look
like right and the vast majority of them
are not in shape and then when you try
to talk to them about the importance of
looking good and signaling masculinity
to women um they start making excuses or
they'll say you know well yeah you know
i'm working on it i've made some you
know advancements but it's like dude if
you're six foot tall and 260 pounds
uh and you're the same age as me
you know she's going to pick me over you
all day long right because yeah i'm
taller than you and i weigh like 215 and
i'm lean and i've got abs you know for
the most part so um
looking good does matter it's not as
hard as
let me just re phrase that it's not as
hard when you're younger right if you're
20 30s it's a lot easier to maintain a
strong masculine physique as you get in
your 40s and i'm not in my 50s yet but
as you get older there's more things you
got to do right i mean you got to be
careful with your food you got to get a
good amount of sleep you can't train the
wrong way otherwise you might injure
yourself you know your skin changes a
little bit you know it gets a little
looser there's certain things you can do
with that
but i mean like the overall optics of
strength and masculinity are are most
easily portrayed
by developing what would look like a
swimmer's body which has the 1.62 golden
ratio meaning your shoulders are 1.6 to
the width of your waistline right which
is very easy to measure like all you
have to do is stand in front of a glass
shower door take a black sharpie and
mark the width of your shoulder then
mark the width of your waist at your
belt line tape measure measure it divide
one in the other and you've got your
ratio right yeah so work
you know so working towards that
is basically the way to go like the uh
johnny bravo like avatar you know the
black shirt cartoon guy with the broad
shoulders and the narrow waist that's an
exaggeration but
go towards you know building your
physique you know looking more towards
that sort of thing right yeah yeah and i
think that's a good thing to put in
the mind of a lot of men because you
know
and as you're saying you know
when you have nice clothes on when you
have a good physique and you look at and
clothes on people do give you more
attention and i've noticed that in
recent years i just get you know part of
the reason i started this podcast was
uh you know i tend to psych myself about
psych myself out about being an expert
like ah people don't want to know this
there's people who know more in the
world you know but i realized that
people were always coming up to me if i
had any part of my body visible asking
advice about fitness and i'm like oh the
typical person
the typical man asking for fitness
advice is actually at a much lower like
entry level um you know
and could use some basic advice about
fitness and nutrition
and i do think
i tend to overthink that and other guys
tend to you know even coming up to me
they're like i want to look like you and
it's like but do you because like i'm
not even saying i have the ideal you
know body for women i probably keep a
little bit more muscle on for certain
things like acting or whatever social
media
you know than if i were to just look at
it as what it you know would be most
attractive to women and also easier to
maintain so i think having those
principles of like you know check your
ratio just measure your shoulders and
your waist and and go towards that and
build this up a little bit and shrink
this that's attainable and it's
realistic because i think um
you know i don't know maybe some of my
listeners have have experienced this but
when i was younger and playing football
i would consider myself sort of bigger
sick where i was like
eating all the time and really like
focused on gaining weight and getting
bigger because a lot of these images
that were
presented with especially if you grew up
in the 80s and there's pro wrestling and
gi joe and he-man you know your notion
is like
huge
muscular uh you know
really excessive and that's kind of your
idea of an ideal
and uh you know even pursuing that i get
a lot of guys like you know you know the
guy in the gym who's like you know
you're like hey look great and he's like
trying to be like you and it's like but
no you're already bigger than me like we
you know and so guys kind of do suffer
from this body dysmorphia if they go
down that path of like
i need to get bigger and if i only had
bigger arms then you know women would be
more attractive but it's like no no no
it's it's really much simpler than that
and it's more attainable than that
yeah it's
it's not like you know the juice is
generally not worth the squeeze right
you know if you're being honest because
you know for a guy like me like i look
at i look at my physique and i'm
thinking to myself okay you know could i
could i build more muscle probably
um do i want to stress my organs you
know more than i'm stressing you know
them right now with the therapeutic dose
of testosterone that i take you know
with trt probably not right yeah you
know do chicks like you know big ass you
know muscular guys generally no
um you know the amount of time you got
to spend working out and eating and you
know watching your diet and all sort of
stuff
it's it's like
it's
it gets the point you know like we use
that term uh bigorexia which i'm
familiar with because i remember it was
i mean like when i was in my 20s there
was um muscle magazines that i assumed
like muscle media 2000 stuff like that
the bill phillips you know publications
and there was always like some sound
bites somewhere about about guys chasing
too much muscle and it's like
look you know unless you're competing on
a stage and and that's your job like
that's your life you don't need to be
walking around with that much muscle
like it's yeah it's going to stress your
body and you're probably going to die
younger yeah yeah i agree and we're
seeing a lot of that more recently
especially with social media because you
maybe hear about these guys who aren't
like the mr olympia winners per se but
they're high level competitive
bodybuilders or maybe coming up in the
ranks and you know these guys will die
in their
40s even down to their 20s because yeah
we've seen a few people in the last
couple years die in their 20s yeah yeah
yeah it's really crazy and i just
and so part of the message i try to talk
about you know anabolics here and be
really honest with it and you know i've
experimented on myself i've been i
played
football in college and i did a few
cycles back then
then went natural for many years and
started again uh in my mid-30s
with trt and i've actually you know
people that's another thing people come
on page and be like it's all steroids
and it's like
the physique that you're commenting on
is actually one that i achieved just
with trt you know and i feel like
for most guys and myself included like
the training and diet aspect of it 150
milligrams or 200 milligrams of
testosterone is often
all you need to achieve you know what
women would consider an ideal physique
and if everything else is in place
they're going to look really good and
the additional you know there's a
logarithmic curve to adding more
compounds or adding anything else on so
as you're saying it's like you know
doing twice the dose isn't going to get
twice the results and is probably going
to have twice the side effects though
and take you down this path of you know
i'd say testosterone is probably about
20 25 of the results that you get i mean
i i've got photographs of myself um
young you're like at 30 and i i would
argue that i look better at 30 natural
um at 193 pounds versus um on
therapeutic testosterone at 215 pounds
yeah right so
it's it's again it's mostly diet
exercise and sleep and yeah just
testosterone build muscle and you know
lean you out of course but
just like you know like these guys that
think that oh it's all
it's all gear it's all juice or you're
just juicing yourself to the gills you
know the sazool's kind of like coming
out like crazy it's like it's not all
that and it's it really isn't yeah and
one of the things that i try to impart
upon people is
if you're looking to like you said you
you achieved a really great physique
you'd consider it better than the
physique you have now with the
therapeutic ghost of test um
naturally and i've done that as well
where i look back and i go oh when i was
29 i had this you know i was leaner and
i was only doing like circuit training
and you know was probably 215 pounds but
like women loved it you know and uh that
wasn't uh
something that i needed to juice for
and um
you know and it's not all the results so
how important
knowing that how important is learning
how to train before you do anything or
learning how to diet before you do
anything because i've yeah some guys
think that's going to be like the thing
that kicks them into being motivated no
i get i get guys in my you know their
20s and they're like uh yeah i uh yeah i
want to get some trt like who's your
doctor it's like dude like if you have
you done blood work for a few years have
you tried to max out naturally are you
taking the right supplements have you
checked your blood labs to see if you're
deficient in anything that helps build
testosterone in your blood sort of thing
and they just want the shortcut dude
like everybody today wants like give me
a pill that i can pop and i'll lose 20
pounds in like 10 days you know let me
rub a cream under my eye and i'll wipe
away you know 15 years of age and that's
what people want like that's what
they're used to they don't want to do
the work they don't want to put in the
time
you know
exogenous testosterone is wonderful and
it can certainly help improve your life
as you get older as a guy but i strongly
encourage all guys to max out naturally
for as long as they can before they
switch over to introducing something in
your body on a regular basis because
it's a lifetime protocol right yeah yeah
and that's something that i always you
know i get different categories of guys
that some guys will be in their 30s and
40s asking about the best trt regimen
and i'm happy to help them but
i do get a lot of younger guys
specifically asking about sarms or they
want to take an anavar only cycle or or
approach it like i just want to do this
one cycle and my mind is taking vitamin
d
are you right you know like you know are
you taking the stuff that actually helps
you like are you sleeping enough you
know like sleep patterns like you know
yeah eating basically are you eating a
lot of soy are you estrogen dominant
insulin resistant in your body like
those those are the things that i would
look at first before i start looking at
sarms or peptides or anabolics or
anything like that yeah getting a gram
of protein and per pound of body weight
that's always something like skinny guys
are like i want to put on muscle but i
can't eat it's like well
you know it's not that hard it's just
somewhat uncomfortable you know to get
that much protein or whatever not that i
think a pound of uh or a gram of protein
per pound of body weight is excessive or
too difficult but you know it's harder
than just taking a pill and i think most
guys
just don't anticipate the kind like if i
were to design you know for whatever
your purpose is let's say i took a guy
who was 30 and you know wanted to use
anabolics
i would look at it as a multi-year plan
i wouldn't look at it as like you know
well yeah just do this you know
eight-week cycle of rad140 or anavar
and then all your problems are gonna be
fixed it's like you're gonna go right
back to where you were
you know um unless you build and do that
and so it's a it's a pathway like either
you're taking
you know test uh for the rest of your
life which i don't think is that
inconvenient enough i'm committed to
that but uh you know for a lot of these
guys they don't realize it's like
this isn't going to solve any of your
problems you know and if you're 22 and
asking about anabolics instead of
maximizing your training you're probably
not training that intensely right the
the um you know the stuff that i love is
when you see these like reddit threads
or or posts that like pop up from time
to time the guy's like yeah i went on
trend for eight weeks and i played video
games the entire time i did no lifting
and like here's my results sort of thing
and it's like
right why
it would never occur to me yeah and i
and i'm maybe it's because
i was so desperate to gain any sort of
muscle and in the 90s it really was
pretty like i didn't think these guys
were on steroids because i never talked
about a magazine so you're looking at
like you know these giant bodybuilders
and they're talking about the creatine
brand that they use and i really bought
so it's like i was i'm like whoa okay
i'm gonna follow their workout do this
and not realizing but
in that process i did you know fall in
love with the
the working out the lifting aspect of it
um you know
which i just think is it's irreplaceable
you know and it is hard if you're in
your i think people can do it but if
you're in your 30s or 40s working out
for the first time
it's a habit that you have to create
yeah absolutely and so do you coach
certain guys who who have never worked
out before
i don't really like to because i just
find there's so much information that's
available out there like i usually just
tell them to buy somebody's course that
i'm you know that i'm familiar with that
i think is good um
but i mean if they demand it then i'll
take the time out and i'll tell them
what i know but um
i just kind of have my own thing man and
it works for me and i've worked it out
and that's what i do um right right
because that's another element is like i
can tell you what i eat and what i do
but you know
something else is going to stick for you
and i do think that's fundamental is
that you enjoy this or or have a logic
of your own for why you do it
i think that you know developing a nice
physique is
you know can be common i think that it's
uncommon to understand the concepts of
unplugging from the matrix and the lies
that we've been sold over the years um
those are the conversations that i think
are more valuable to guys yeah um
because i mean like like
developing a nice physique isn't that
hard it's pick up heavy [ __ ] put it down
eat well sleep properly get the right
nutrients in your body agreed even
though the fitness industry wants to
make it seem esoteric and complicated
it's like yeah it boils down to a few
things so on top of fitness you know
because again we're using that as a
launching off point to say okay once you
have that figured out which you should
but take your own path to do it there's
lots of information out there what are
the other things that you would
uh
sort of describe as the elements of
masculinity that we're missing today in
society for the most part and that you
help guys develop
yourself
yeah okay yeah you know leading as a guy
because um a lot of a lot of men today
they've been conditioned their entire
lives to like really never stand up to
women they've been you know they've been
told just bend the knee and you know be
a shoulder to cry on and uh
you know women will flock to you like
just be yourself you know like just be a
nice guy is what a lot of um
a lot of guys get as far as messaging
today either from single mother
household or maybe even grew up in a
household with two parents but the
father was a bit of a simp and you know
like a lot of this happy wife happy life
narrative um it's it's infused
in most men's dna and all the messaging
that they hear see and do and it's like
that doesn't work that's not what
attracts women that's not what keeps
girls around um that's a lie and if you
want to believe that that's cool that
just leaves more women for the rest of
us that have figured it out but
unplugging from the matrix is a process
that takes some time and if you you know
if you're 35 years old when i start
talking to you and you're looking at my
content or you read my book and we start
doing some private consults um
it's it's dealing with 35 years of
programming and lies that you've
believed believe that i need to unplug
you from and that just doesn't take one
or two calls that can take quite a bit
of time most guys really really struggle
with the unplugging process because
they'll go and read my book or they'll
watch a few of my podcasts and they'll
be oh okay well that makes sense now
like now i think i understand that and
then they'll just kind of like run off
and get into a marriage or they'll get
into a relationship and then six months
later they'll be like i screwed up rich
you know i i became a simp again or i
went through beta tization again i don't
know like how that happened it's like
because you suck
like unplugging is a
you know it's like working out right
like you got to put in the reps every
week you know it's like eating the right
thing it's like
you know the same sort of stuff when it
comes to dealing with women one of the
easiest ways you know so i can give your
audience a little bit of a tip so one of
the easiest ways for you to
develop a far better
relationship with women and condition
yourself is when you're when you're
texting back and forth like when you're
doing the messaging part stuff whether
it's with a girlfriend you're dating or
you're you know dating multiple women
whatever it happens to be before you hit
send and you know there's some stuff
going back and forth which
because once you send that like she's
got that message right so if you read it
out loud and you're like okay hang on
maybe i'm behaving a bit like a simple
over here or i don't have the frame in
the conversation or i'm yielding to her
too much sort of thing you can you know
backspace and delete that and rewrite it
sort of thing so
that's an area that i always encourage
guys to spend some time on you know when
it comes to developing yourself as a
strong confident guy that gets good
results with women over a long term
basis is pay attention to your messaging
yeah i know i think that's a great
response and
um
i it reminds me of somebody who i was
working with recently who was sending me
some messages because you know like i i
do texting women happens to be something
like you practice a lot and you get good
at it just based on like this got
results and this didn't right so um it's
it's an area that i do feel at least
confident in in uh you know giving some
advice and often this is this comes down
to brevity you know and being
interesting and so this guy was sending
me these blocks of you know hello queen
good morning what restaurant do you want
to go to and i'm like oh my god you know
you know you'd have a field day with it
but a lot of this is like
as you were saying it's this kind of
like hello anything you want would you
like to do that you know and so this
this idea of like you know what's the
opposite of leadership submissiveness
and you might be looking for that in a
woman and that's great but like
i think a lot of guys don't get that
it's like this is an analogy for
everything you know successful guys
aren't submitting to everybody else who
they're going up against because this is
you know life and business and any
endeavor you go in where there's a
valuable prize at the end is going to be
a competition you know the notion of
game isn't just used on women that
you're dating the notion of game is like
you know for me like i've got my
gardeners here today um you know there
are two women that run the gardening you
know crew that uh takes care of my
property and it's like i gain them you
know like when i go outside say hi and
i'm talking them and you know and see
what's going on i apply game to that
right yeah
so you know you can use it in all areas
of life and it's it's not that
complicated once you once you see the
code in the matrix once you unplug from
the lies again most people most men
sleepwalk through life they don't
understand what women are attracted to
guys get so pissed off when they're like
well i was her friend and i was a
shoulder to cry on and then you know
like why did she go off and [ __ ] mr
exciting you know sort of thing why did
she go off and bang a guy that looks
like mark basically you know what their
what their complaint is and it's well
it's because you're simping for her
right like you're giving her a
free unlimited attention which she's
absorbing
and that's one of the common problems
you know with society today is like it's
very easy you know for women to get
attention you know if you look at how
men and women use cameras you know for
example women generally will hold the
selfie up and they'll take pictures of
themselves men will generally hold their
camera up and they'll take pictures of
things cars you know whatever it is they
happen to be doing um and you know the
thing with women that you gotta
understand is that attention is if a
form of currency for them and when you
understand that
if you take attention away from them if
they're misbehaving then that makes them
want you more right yeah it's a whole
cat thing right like you don't chase a
cat around if you want to pet it you
just have to sit down and the cat will
generally come to you yeah i agree and i
was going to say earlier i am a cat guy
and i have often described to people
most of what i know about women i see as
an analogy to cats because it's a matter
of you know you can't pursue too hard
you even your body language and just
being confident and being smooth and not
being jerky and erratic and looking all
around and you know modulating your
voice correctly there's so much of it
that applies just because you know it's
like you're dealing with a sensitive
smaller thing that's going to react very
um you know sensitively to everything
you do even if you don't realize it you
know and that's i think how women in the
rest of the world you know it's a great
analogy for that because it's like no
people are watching people are seeing
everything you do and the difference in
your body language your attitude or the
words to use
you know will make all the difference in
the world so
um i think that pretty much covers it i
know uh you got a meeting after this so
i don't want to hold you too long but
just wanted to say thank you so much
you're the first interview on haters
will say via zoom i thought it went
really well and i'd love for my audience
to check out more of your work uh you
have two youtube channels entrepreneurs
and cars and you're transferring most of
your work over to the unplugged alpha
yeah there's a new channel i set up it's
called the umph it's uh just where the
podcast is going to live and uh if you
haven't got the uh the book the
literature is on amazon it's just the
unplugged alpha and you can grab it
there it's in print kindle and audible
as well fantastic book and also people
can reach out to get personal
consultations with you right if you want
to get a little more one-on-one comments
yeah if you look me up on social media
there's a link tree there with all my
social my community and my courses like
all that stuff sir awesome well thank
you again so much and i hope we uh have
another conversation in the future
thanks mark all right take care rich all
right guys i hope you enjoy the
interview with richard cooper i'm going
to be doing more of these hopefully in
the future uh i will still be doing solo
episodes but i'm really excited about
having some of the people who i watch
online and admire
onto the show so i've already reached
out to a number of people have some
great guests lined up and i want you all
to feel free to drop your suggestions in
the comments uh maybe it's people that i
know of that i can just get a better
idea of is the demand out there to hear
from these people and maybe it's
somebody that i've never heard of
i'm open to all suggestions so please
drop them below and let's keep the
conversation going
you